what does loving yourself actually mean
it's an ability to be able to walk into
any room exactly as you are being
yourself and leaving that room not
worrying what everyone else thinks of
you because you have this absolute
ability to respect who you are to love
the person that you are to feel proud of
who you are that you are have the
freedom and liberation of being yourself
but further than that it's also about
being able to honor where you're at day
to day it's about being able to check in
with yourself constantly and know how
you're feeling physically energetically
mentally and offering yourself what you
need whilst also simultaneously being
able to honor where you want to be
tomorrow and it's finding that amazing
balance